rentrée décalée pour les templiers les
élans courtois ne commenceront pas leur
saison ce mois de janvier comme
d'habitude leur premier match de
deuxième division est programmée début
mars contre les dockers de nantes
la décision a été prise par la
fédération française il devrait
également y avoir moins de matches cette
saison
la saison va être écourtée à cause du
courant d'un virus et j'en espère fort
le plus de matches possibles donc du
coup aller en play-offs et gagner la
frustration est énorme à la fois pour le
club est à la fois pour le joueur
surtout quand on est extrêmement motivé
mais on a la chance on fait d'avoir une
famille templiers qui restent très
soudés dans cette période compliquée
decaux vide avec des entraînements plus
limité donc oui oui il ya une
frustration c'est évident une saison
décalé des incertitudes sur le
calendrier deux éléments qui ont
entraîné des baisses de sponsoring pour
cette saison 2021
le club doit donc faire face à la crise
et s'adapter non le club n'est pas en
danger il a nécessité en fait qu'on
prenne des décisions stratégiques et on
continue à prendre des décisions
stratégiques aujourd'hui pour protéger
des intérêts du club pour vivre dans ce
minima en limitant les investissements
par exemple on se pose la question de
savoir si on maintient ou pas l'arrivée
d'un joueur américain cette année
s'il n'y a pas de saison n'y a aucun
aucune raison de faire des engagements
financiers pour être prêt pour la
reprise les templiers continue à
s'entraîner régulièrement rendez vous
début mars pour la reprise de la saison
si le contexte sanitaire le permet